bonjour bienvenue à strasbourg nous
sommes ensemble pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne dans europe hebdo
dans cette émission direction l'ukraine
depuis trois mois les opposants au
président ianoukovitch camper place
maïdan à kiev la semaine dernière les
violences ont repris
bilan 80 de mort et la communauté
internationale s'active pour sortir le
pays du blocage politique et économique
mais d'abord l'actualité vous pensiez en
avoir fini avec les organismes
génétiquement modifiés
et bien pas vraiment alors faut-il
s'attendre à avoir des ogm dans notre
assiette c'est la question de la semaine
on pensait en avoir terminé après tout
on avait voté un moratoire non les ogm
pas chez nous jamais on pensait
travailler à une agriculture durable
respectueuse et la faute de consensus au
sein des 28 lors d'une réunion des
ministres des affaires européennes
voilà que la commission autorise la
culture du maïs tc 15 07 du fabricant
pioneer contre l'avis de la majorité des
états membres et du parlement européen
branle bas de combat la france se dit
déterminée à interdire la culture sur
son sol mais le sénat rejette la
proposition de loi est depuis des années
le conseil d'état casse tous les
moratoires et autres clauses de
sauvegarde arguant du manque d'éléments
scientifiques nouveaux ou vend les
risques des organismes génétiquement
modifiés
alors pourquoi ne pas cultiver les ogm
alors à quand les ogm dans notre
assiette
et alors qui mieux que josé bové pour
répondre à cette question bonjour merci
d'être avec nous bonjour donc on ne vous
présente plus vous êtes vice-président
ici au sein de ce parlement de la
commission agriculture et développement
rural et vous êtes candidat à la
présidence de la commission européenne
pour les verts européens avec ce cas
quelle heure allemande
josé bosé après tout ce tintouin là on
en parle depuis des années des ogm
pourquoi est-ce contesterait pas
finalement écouté jeu sont assez simples
il y a eu une étude indépendante qui
avait été faite par le docteur séralini
sur les aspects sanitaires
elle a été compté cela est invalide à
l'aide elle a été contestée par beaucoup
de gens moi j'en ai parlé avec l'agent
sur open sanitaire des aliments ils sont
d'accord pour dire il faut mettre en
place un protocole scientifique sur
cette question des risques à long terme
pour la santé
donc maintenant ce qu'on attend
simplement et il ça devrait se faire
dans les mois qui viennent que l' agence
européenne et des agences nationales se
mettent d'accord sur le protocole
scientifique avec aussi des chercheurs
indépendants et qu'on lance ce processus
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut faire
parce que ça n'a jamais été fournis aux
internats
à date heure le professeur séralini donc
à monter en fait une étude sur six mois
je crois sur nogent 2 heures pardon sur
des rails s'est avéré en fait que
l'ingestion à long terme en fait dodo gm
a provoqué en fait des cancers du foie
des excroissances s'en souvient un petit
peu tous de ces images effectivement de
rats complètement déformés donc cette
étude a été invalidée et ne fait plus
partie de la littérature scientifique
est ce qu'au fond
on peut faire confiance en fait à ces
études là le problème c'est que depuis
des années on demande à ce qu'il y ait
des études qu'ils soient organisés au
niveau européen et avec les pays membres
de manière complètement indépendant
c'est quelque chose grâce je dirais à
l'étude de monsieur séralini qui a
montré semble-t-il un certain nombre
d'insulaires mais moi je suis pas
scientifique non plus tout le monde se
met d'accord poney il faut le faire donc
mettons en oeuvre cette étude et on aura
comme ça des éléments qui ne pourront
plus être discuté ou qui pourront
permettre d'autres étudiants c'est
pourquoi on la fait pas cette étude où
est le problème finalement scellé fond
c'est quoi les fausses et pas pour un
véritable problème parce que c'est
relativement limité on parle de 3
millions à peu près pour mener cette
étude
donc c'est quelque chose c'est au niveau
européen est tout à fait possible
maintenant il faut qu'il ait une volonté
politique et que l' agence européenne et
le feu vert pour le faire donc j'espère
que dans les prochains mois les choses
vont demeurer ça a été actée comme une
nécessité donc tout le monde est
d'accord
alors moi je vais je vais jouer un petit
peu l'avocat du diable mais après tout
aux états unis on en mange depuis 15 ans
sans que ça pose particulièrement le
problème semble-t-il on en importe on
apporte entre 300000 et 500 mille tonnes
enfin je j'ai pu exactement les chiffres
en tête mais après tout il n'ya pas une
forme de diray de de cynisme à se dire
non nous on veut pas en cultiver mais on
continue d'importer la plupart des bêtes
en fait en mange donc pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas cultiver finalement alors
d'abord sur les études sanitaires
communs a dit si on ne veut pas chercher
on trouve pas donc à partir du moment où
on n'y a pas d'étude on peut pas savoir
quelles sont les conséquences sanitaires
mais d'autres problèmes se posent des
problèmes environnementaux
les transfert de gène sur les autres
cultures donc ça ça pose avait été un
problème
les problèmes sur les insectes non
ciblés qui deviennent résistants y
compris des insectes cibles donc les
générations futures sont beaucoup plus
résistant les plantes qui deviennent
elles-mêmes résistantes aux herbicides
et ce faisant les mauvaises herbes entre
guillemets de la même manière deviennent
résistants ça pose énormément de
problèmes et donc on a un problème très
large y compris des problèmes
économiques pour savoir
si ça va pas entraîner des distorsions
de concurrence donc tout ça doit être
étudiée et mis au même niveau que les
questions sanitaires
bon alors josé bové vous venez de
publier en fait ce livre qui est
absolument incroyable puisqu'il
s'appelle hold up à bruxelles et on lit
ça vraiment comme un polar vous nous
raconter en fait les arcanes de toutes
ces agences et notamment l'efsa donc l'
agence européenne qui en charge entre
autres de la question des ogm et vous
pointer les problèmes en fait des lobbys
et des conflits d'intérêts entre les
gens qui sont à la tête de cette agence
et l'industrie agroalimentaire les
biotechnologies et c est ce qu on n'a
pas un petit peu laisser bruxelles et
notamment ses agences aux mains de de
ces industries agroalimentaire et
biotechnologique
alors il faut rappeler que donc cette
agence européenne sanitaire des aliments
aesa en français efsa en anglais est né
en 2002 après la crise de la vache folle
et c'est effectivement donc un progrès
c'était quelque chose d'important à
mettre en oeuvre pour étudier l'ensemble
des questions c'est pas simplement les
ogm ce sont les pesticides les colorants
l'aspartame tous ces sujets sont
étudiées par cette agence le problème
c'est que ça a été mis en oeuvre et en
fait y'a pas eu véritablement de
contrôle derrière pour vérifier comment
ça fonctionnait et je me suis rendu
compte en étant ici au parlement
européenne qui avait des choses bizarres
d'abord les experts souvent viennent de
l'industrie
premier problème souvent les éléments
qui certes a analysé par exemple les ogm
sont directement les éléments fournis
par monsanto donc monsanto dépose une
demande de nouvel ogm et on les teste à
partir des normes de monsanto
ça pose évidemment à deuxième problème
est le troisième problème je dirais le
plus grand c'est que je me suis rendu
compte et j'ai mené l enquête que la
présidente de cette agence était elle
même issue du plus gros lobby de l'agro
alimentaire mondial qui s'appelle l'ilsi
qui est un sigle pas du tout connu qui a
des antennes dans tous les continents et
cette personne était membre du conseil
d'administration et elle l'avait caché
donc c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
incroyable
et quand le parlement européen suite à
ma révélation s'est rendu compte de cela
et bien a refusé de voter le quitus à
cette agence
et cette personne a été contrainte de
démissionner là on était vraiment dans
le conflit d'intérêt majeur
je conseille effectivement la lecture
parce que ça c'est vraiment comme un
polar josé bové je disais tout à l'heure
que vous étiez aussi candidat à la
présidence de la commission pour les
verts je voudrais qu'on écoute une de
vos potentiels entre guillemets enfin
votre consoeur au sein de ce parlement
est votre adversaire politique on écoute
est-ce que vous effectuerez tout votre
mandat de député européen
c'était lui et bien sûr en mai prochain
el ghazi rejetée par atmo là bas je ne
sais pas si c'est ce que je serai élue
présidente de la république en 2010 est
serait obligé d'interrompre son mandat
de député européen
j'ai pas pour toute la législature
européenne
un beau si les français décident de me
porter à l'elysée présidentielle et je
pense que je pense qu nettement mes
électeurs le comprendront donc trait
d'humour de marine le pen sur le plateau
de public sénat il ya quelques jours
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
sondages qui indiquent que le front
national est aujourd'hui le premier
parti de france à ce que à quoi vous
vous attendez lors de l'élection du 25
mai prochain
les choses sont en train de bouger et je
crois que les les français notamment
mais je pense que c'est la réalité pour
les autres européens sont en train de se
rendre compte aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a
pas de solutions aux crises je dire au
pluriel économique sociale ou
environnementale sans un renforcement en
europe
aujourd'hui la solution des crises
passent par l'europe si on veut faire en
sorte qu'il y ait une harmonisation
sociale fiscale si on veut permettre aux
jeunes de retrouver de l'emploi ça va
passer par l'europe la reconversion
écologique de l'industrie pour faire
face au changement climatique
ça passe par l'europe donc il va falloir
investir au niveau européen dont je
crois que là-dessus des gens se sont en
train de se rendre compte et si on
demande aux français concrètement si on
va en safin catégorie par catégorie
sociale les gens ne rejette pas l'europe
au contraire simplement ils ne veulent
pas de cette europe là et je crois que
c'est ça la grande différence
les gens sont pro européens mais ils
n'acceptent pas une europe qui soit
technocratique alors les gens sont prêts
européens ça reste effectivement à
démontrer alors quand vous voulez bon là
on en attendant quand on en entend
parler c'est plutôt l'europe c'est
plutôt l'europe des banques et pas
l'europe des peuples on peut la
rejoindre
c'est pour ça non on veut changer
d'europe les gens ne remettent pas même
le rôle pourrait quand même d'accord et
jean françois copé qui pourrait dire
j'aime tellement l'europe que je voulais
changer
je trouve intéressant de voir monsieur
copé dire cela alors qu'ils restent dans
un modèle très anciens d'europe
intergouvernementale aujourd'hui quand
on dit plus d'europe ça veut dire qu'il
faut des idées il faut une souveraineté
c'est ce que dit daniel cohn bendit il
faut les états unis transcrivez ça
j'aurais réalisme européen je crois
qu'il faut aller plus haut à 0 caution
veut garder une souveraineté française
il faut renforcer la souveraineté
européenne
et quand on voit ce qui se passe à kiev
avec des gens qui brandissent le drapeau
européen
c'est pas pour entrer demain dans
l'europe mais c'est pour dire ce sont
les valeurs de démocratie et
transparence qu'on veut chez nous alors
justement la transition à l'impeccable
parce que justement on va partir à kiev
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la position
de l'europe sur ce conflit en ukraine
est ce qu'on n'a pas été trop tard et et
pas assez vite
je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre de
d'atermoiements qui ont été à mon avis
négatif
on aurait dû taper l'europe madame
ashton aurait dû taper du poing sur la
table beaucoup plus vite
il faut qu'on aide d'abord les
ukrainiens à faire des élections qui
soient vraiment transparente et sont
prévues le même jour que l'élection
européenne c'est un petit clin d'oeil
mais qui est très intéressant ça c'est
le premier set et puis ensuite il va
falloir organiser une réunion des
donateurs pour véritablement metzer 9
mai pour que pas il faudra faire
attention que ça soit pas une réunion
technocratique qui est vraiment des
responsables politiques et qu'on assène
pas au peuple ukrainien
un régime absolument insupportable merci
josé bové justement nous continue
direction place maïdan depuis trois mois
les opposants au président ianoukovitch
campaient sur cette bien nommée place de
l'indépendance
motif l'arrêt brutal des négociations
avec l'europe et le retour entre
guillemets dans le giron russe et une
corruption endémique de la part des
gouvernants nous étions à kiev pour
rencontrer un petit peu les
protagonistes quand la révolte a éclaté
bilan une centaine de morts et depuis
les instances internationales sont au
chevet de l'ukraine
c'est un reportage de jérôme rhabiller
20h place maidana kiev le mardi 18
février
la police charge les manifestants
installés là depuis plus de trois mois
une union de la révolution ukrainienne à
110 phase finale
la veille encore le calme régnait comme
depuis trois semaines manifestants et
policiers se font face dans une rue qui
borde la place est sur les barricades
on réclame encore et toujours le départ
du président ce timbre poste ou bien
nous convient et là pour que
ianoukovitch taille dégage sale
criminels dégage il est au pouvoir
depuis quatre ans quatre ans et rien n'a
changé combien de gens sont en
difficulté
combien sont dans la pauvreté les
pensions de retraite c'est 600 700
grivnas on ne peut pas vivre avec ça le
gaz est cher le prix des aliments
augmentent tout devient plus cher dans
ce no man's land le sol témoignent des
affrontements et côté policier le
discours est à la baisse
ce sont des ukrainiens comme nous je ne
les considère pas comme des criminels il
faut espérer qu'il n'y aura plus
d'événements comme ceux de janvier que
nos hommes politiques seront
suffisamment raisonnables et patient
pour trouver une solution parce que
l'affrontement
ce n'est pas bien c'est un chemin qui
mène nulle part
c'est pour cela qu'il doit trouver un
compromis
fin novembre 2013 à la surprise générale
le président ukrainien viktor
ianoukovitch refuse de signer un accord
commercial et d'association avec l'union
européenne
ils préfèrent se tourner vers moscou qui
offre 15 milliards de dollars et à
rabais sur les prix du gaz
car les caisses du pays sont vides le
défaut de paiement n'est pas loin une
mauvaise stratégie pour igor bourakovski
économistes à kiev est clair que
l'harmonisation de notre marché avec le
marché européen
c'est un vrai investissement pour le
futur car il s'agit de réformes
structurelles dans l'ukraine a besoin
aux abords de la place les manifestants
se prépare un nouvel affrontement ici
l'accord avec le est passée au second
plan
la priorité désormais au départ du
président dans les rues de milly
d'autodéfense côtoient des femmes et des
hommes de tous âges pas question pour
eux de lâcher la place maïdan devenu le
symbole de l'ukraine indépendante et
cadeaux pro d2 marge brute shine n'en
peux plus les gens sont à bout
ce sont les ukrainiens intelligents qui
sont ici vous comprenez les gens sont à
bout
tout le monde doit être présent ici vous
n'avez pas honte de nous regarder dans
les yeux
mais non vous n'avez pas honte mais je
n'avais pas la toile il ya tout monsieur
je suis là parce que nous voulons tous
vivre dans un pays différent dans un
pays où les lois sont respectées
willy un véritable état de droit pas
dans un pays dirigé par des lois faites
par des criminels ou la règle le
pistonnage et ou un clan s'accapare
toutes les richesses
l'état de droit un voeu pieux depuis
décembre de nombreux manifestants ont
disparu ont été torturées ou emprisonnés
la contestation s'organise et des
associations de tente de protéger les
droits des opposants sauceda ce que
tient euros maidan sos bonjour tob je
vous écoute nice materna toge tombe bien
qu en ukraine il existe la présomption
d'innocence ce n'est pas respecter tous
les arrêtés d'euros maidan sont par
exemple ranger dans la catégorie
criminelle
déçu par l'attentisme européen les
insurgés de maidan n'espère plus grand
chose du lieu continent noyades ont eu
chaud starmania
je pense que la position des
manifestants de maidana évoluer
vis-à-vis de l'europe
on est passé d'un certain romantisme un
euro réalisme ils comprennent désormais
que la situation en ukraine doit être
décidé par les ukrainiens eux mêmes
les trois mois de contestation déjà
apporté un petit souffle de liberté des
médias indépendants non détenues par des
hommes politiques des oligarques proche
de la russie ont émergé à expresso tv
chaîne diffuse en 24 heures sur 24 sur
internet est lancé au moment des
événements on aspire à être un acteur du
changement cocaïne toro hier les
manifestions d'oran my dad se sont
rassemblés devant le domicile du
procureur général ukrainien viktor
pchonka j'adorerais pensé et je pense
que notre chaîne est un des déclencheurs
qui peut permettre d'accompagner le
changement c'est ça qui est beau dans
cette situation parce que vous pouvez
voir que des gens normaux des
journalistes des militants de tous bords
viennent sur scène et 10
vous pouvez faire changer les choses
vous pouvez changer les choses et c'est
pour cela que ça vaut le coup de faire
ce travail que ça vaut le coup de rester
ici en ukraine plus de vingt ans après
la chute du bloc soviétique
l'ukraine cherche encore sa place entre
russie et europe
l'aspiration à plus de liberté à sonner
la révolte
reste à connaître le prix ap
où va l'ukraine c'est la question que je
vais poser à nos deux invités bonjour
marielle de sarnez
vous revenez de kiev où vous avez été
avec certaines personnes de votre groupe
libéraux démocrates la semaine dernière
brice hortefeux vous êtes également par
lino vous êtes député de membre du parti
populaire européen on ne vous présente
plus marielle de sarnez quel a été votre
sentiment quand vous étiez sur place
j'avais déjà été sur place le 8 décembre
lors des grandes manifestations qui
avaient lieu après la première
impression vous savez quand les forces
armées sont arrivés sur la place le
matin à 5 heures du matin qu'ils ont
faits prisonniers
très très nombreux étudiants ce qui
avait beaucoup touché les ukrainiens
même bouleversé ces images les
ukrainiens et en fait c'était un
sentiment très différents lui décembre
c'était une espèce d'euphorie d'
enthousiasme
il était là sur la place à brandir des
drapeaux ukrainiens et européens dans
une révolution heureuse comme ça et puis
là c'était une tout autre ambiance était
au lendemain de tous ces morts c'était
une ambiance absolument glaçante
la place était noire elle avait été
brûlée il y avait une
une amertume et en même temps une
détermination et une colère extrêmement
fortes dans la nuit où je suis allé à
maidan avec guy verhofstadt donc une
ambiance très différente d'un peuple qui
avait vu les siens tombés sous les
balles ordonnée par le président donc
c'était quelque chose d'extrêmement
l'eau et puis ensuite les événements se
sont accélérés extrêmement rapidement
c'est à dire qu'en fait en 24 heures
tout a basculé la médiation européenne
est arrivée sur place qui était une
bonne chose avec le ministre et sa place
trangères français je dis que c'est une
bonne chose parce qu'on a toujours des
médiations qui sont plutôt ceux toujours
les polonais ou les allemands qui sont
présents en ukraine que la france était
là c'était bien on peut dire que c'était
peut-être peut-être un peu trop tard
justement je vais vous poser la question
mais alors là ça a fonctionné justement
brice hortefeux on a vu certaines une
notamment de libération qui disait
l'ukraine trahis par leur art en soi
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
constat il n'a pas été c'est un constat
qui est un constat qui doit-être honnête
et lucide
quel est ce constat d'abord c'est que la
france a été absente en vérité
ensuite que la france au sein de
l'europe a elle même été absente et que
le fck l'europe a été trop absents en
clair la france elle était absente
on a une démonstration qui est flagrante
hélas c'est que dans la semaine qui a
précédé le départ du président est
chrétien et barack obama s'est entretenu
à trois reprises avec la chancelière
angela merkel à deux reprises avec
damien david cameron pas avec le
président français deuxième observation
au sein de l'europe la france ne s'est
pas particulièrement fait entendre et
enfin l'europe oui a été un peu absente
un peu trop absente un peu trop lente à
quoi le voit-on ans le voit dans la
durée parce que l'europe n'a pas su
établir un dialogue avec les russes
et on sait que la question ukrainienne
repose sur un dialogue avec la russie
pour une raison simple c'est que la
russie c'est en gros le tiers de la
population ukrainienne qui est
russophone et une partie de la
population à l'ouest qui elle plutôt
européenne et donc ça passe au thème
automatiquement par ce dialogue et ce
dialogue n'a pas existé
donc on paie effectivement un retard
pardonnez moi l'expression à l'allumage
alors justement ce retard à l'allumage
on a un problème aujourd'hui de crise
financière en ukraine ce qui les a
poussés d'ailleurs au mois de décembre a
arrêté à se tourner plutôt vers la
russie on estime à 35 milliards en fait
les besoins de l'ukraine
est-ce que c'est à l'europe de payer
comme on semble le voir aujourd'hui aux
radios intéressant oui c'est un problème
accumulés au fond depuis dix ans
l'ukraine c'était un payés avec des
ressources extrait sain pays riches
potentiellement mais qui a une économie
et d'agriculture qui doivent être
modernisées et donc ils sont dans une
très mauvaise situation économique
ils sont dans une mauvaise situation
économique parce qu'ils n'ont pas fait
les réformes nécessaires chez eux et ils
sont dans une mauvaise situation
économique parce qu'ils ont justement
cette relation avec la russie bien sûr
qu'il faut qu'on parle avec la russie
c'est évident qu'on va pas écartelée
l'ukraine entre l'europe et la russie
elle regarde vers l'europe parce que
l'europe est elle la voit comme une
perspective de progrès or ils ont besoin
d'un progrès démocratique économique et
en même temps évidemment qu'ils ont une
histoire et une frontière commune avec
la russie mais par exemple prix du gaz
le fait que ça fasse le yoyo et que la
russie en effet au fond un argument
politique de chantage politique depuis
des années c'est paraissant avec les
traîne avec des prix du gaz très très
haut par moments évidemment tout ceci
fragilisation de nombreuses crises
deuxième quand on dit mais les russes
ont donné trois billards ils vont
peut-être pas donné les 3 milliards qui
viennent à qui il a laissé 3 milliards
là vous savez le cren c'est un des pays
le système politique ukrainien pas le
pays deux systèmes politiques est un des
plus corrompus de la planète et tous les
gens tous tout le monde a vu tous les
téléspectateurs la maison de
ianoukovitch la maison en la maison on
me disait landais voile à un ris
ianoukovitch et donc où aller cet argent
alors maintenant la question c'est que
cet argent il doit aller l'europe doit t
dès demain elle a des instruments pour
le faire elle doit aider à
l'investissement parce qu'au fond
investissements ces réformes
structurelles forme de structure alors
est-ce qu'on a les moyens brice
hortefeux d'aider l'ukraine à l'heure où
il a fallu
aider chypre la grèce le sud c'est la
question ne porte pas de la même
dimension et l'ukraine en résumé c'est
la population de l'espagne avec un
produit intérieur brut qui est celui du
portugal donc on mesure avec ces deux
éléments est toute la question tout le
défi que l'on que l'on doit relever il
ya une réalité c'est que l'ukraine avait
un potentiel de croissance très
important qui dépasse les 5% qui est
tombé malheureusement à 2 et le que
l'ukraine à 72 75 milliards de dettes et
notamment 28 28 à l'égard de la russie
et c'est donc là encore une fois
souligner toute la difficulté qui doit
être que l'europe doit surmonter pour
aider ce pays
aujourd'hui l'europe s'oriente vers une
position qui à mon avis n'est pas
satisfaisante puisque l'europe a
tendance à dire que c'est le fmi qui
doit y faire face c'est donc un sujet
dont nous devons nous emparer et
d'ailleurs lors du congrès du ppe de
groupes politiques qui se tient la
semaine prochaine à dublin
nous accueillerons ioulia timochenko qui
viendra s'exprimer et rappelé le besoin
l'opposante historique incarcéré
l'ancien premier ministre est qu'il
viendra exprimé les besoins de l'ukraine
à cette occasion
alors il y avait un des intervenants ce
reportage qui avait une remarque à vous
adresser directement on les écoute
je n'étais pas respectés ou neutres
vraiment parler d'une intégration avec
l'union européenne efficace si la
majorité des ukrainiens n'ont jamais
traversé la frontière avec lui
en fait nous sommes séparés de l'europe
par un mur de papier par un mur des
visas et de la pauvreté
est ce qu'il ya une part de cynisme de
parler effectivement de l'ukraine petite
soeur entre guillemets de l'europe et de
laisser ses et craignant en dehors de
cette frontière si la question et lui
craig doit-elle adhérer rapidement à
l'union européenne la réponse est non
elle n'en a pas aujourd'hui les moyens
la possibilité et l'europe n'a pas les
moyens et la possibilité de les
accueillir pour des raisons d'ailleurs
économique financière que je viens de
rap aux appartenances ce qui était
envisagé c'était un par nos partenariats
privilégiés c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
était l'une des causes de ce qui s'est
déroulé pertes donnez-moi d'ivoire aussi
un symbole très fort nous sommes
aujourd'hui engagés dans une période où
il y aura des élections européennes
c'est à dire que les citoyens européens
devront se prononcer et on sent dans un
grand nombre de pays des 28 pays la
communauté européenne
la scepticisme à l'égard de l'europe et
bien finalement ce qui s'est passé en
ukraine c'est aussi une leçon pour nous
européens ça nous rappelle que l'europe
suscite des envies et des espoirs et
donc c'est un élément aussi très positif
vous êtes d'accord marielle de sarnez
est-ce qu'il faut laisser l'ukraine en
dehors de l'europe entre guillemets il
faut qu'on se comprenne que ce qui se
passe en ukraine là il ya évidemment
cette demande de perspectives mais c'est
parce que pour eux l'europe elle est
vécue comme un levier vraiment de
progrès il faut vraiment comprendre ça
les ukrainiens qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
qu'ils soient de l'ouest ou de l'ouest
ou de l'est
ils veulent en finir avec la corruption
ils veulent vivre décemment
ils veulent aussi au fond bénéficier des
valeurs aujourd'hui européenne est à de
droit liberté de la presse justice
indépendante respect des libertés
individuelles et publiques qu'ils n'ont
pas chez eux donc ils sont privés chez
eux
ça c'est le premier point est donc il
faut qu'on soit à leurs côtés pour
favoriser cette transition démocratique
et ses réformes économiques dont ils ont
besoin c'est très important pour soient
vigilants et à leurs côtés et puis après
il ya la question de l'avenir de
l'europe
il faut repenser l'architecturé de
l'europe plus d'intégration d'un côté et
en même temps avoir cette europe qui
peut être effectivement apaisé et
puissante sur le continent européen
alors dernière question est-ce qu'il
faut s'attendre à une partition
on voit qu'il ya des tensions quand même
entre 7 l'ukraine de l'ouest cette crème
de lait ce qui regarde plus vers la
russie imaginer que l'ukraine peut se
stabilise et demain sans un dialogue
profond entre la russie l'ukraine et
l'europe se raconter des histoires on a
besoin évidemment de parler avec poutine
mais poutine a besoin d'entendre aussi
que l'ukraine a son propre avenir à
écrire est ce que vous êtes d'accord
brice hortefeux est ce qu'on peut parler
avec vladimir poutine
et bien c'est fait la question n'est pas
de le pouvoir c'est un devoir et
précisément l'enjeu c'est d'éviter une
partition de l'ukraine et il ya
certainement des tentations et il faut
donc les dépasser
comment les dépasser la solution elle
est très simple très claire elle et
j'allais dire quasi unique
cela passe par un dialogue entre l'union
européenne et la russie et cela doit te
reposer sur une évolution de la
conception du dialogue entre l'union
européenne et le voisin russe
parce que jusqu'à présent ce dialogue
était extrêmement faible
écoutez merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
vous pour évoquer ce dossier risque nous
on continue bien entendu à suivre cette
question rendez vous en attendant la
semaine prochaine avec ahmed tazir à
bruxelles bonne suite de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires